seniori siamo qui oggi per giocare a the
sims l'hanno fatto anche per consolle
quindi posso stare seduto sul mio divano
con il mio didietro appoggiato sui
cuscini morbidi e fare le stesse cose
che facevo su pc io ho felice premix per
iniziare l'ex law and every bari acqua
questo generare a caso i suoi abiti che
tre duro e questo è mio zio antonio ma
come antonio grande un po più allenato
di mio zio però ci trasferiamo stavolta
nel deserto osi springs io mi metto
sempre nelle città con le normali primo
a fare una città a normale per una volta
bello fatemi vedere la reggia che ho
appena acquistato o acquistato questa
roba per 17mila simoleon ma me le hanno
incluse le bevande nel frigo almeno si è
un po strana come casa effettivamente
prova anche perché piove dentro ci sono
i buchi ma chi è questo ma ma vai via va
disse ma chi ti conosce via via poi
terminare in anticipo sembra che tutti
si divertano a tutti chi tutti kg c'è
solo sto tizio papava figurativa via via
via ma che me ne frega fuori da casa mia
via sloggiare veloci sentire eccola lì
con questa dei parlanti che anche triste
corri corri fai l'uomo corri alla
presentazione corte il prestazioni di
amichevole veloce veloce mazzano che
voglia di vivere che già sta tizia
katrina caliente chiama katrina caliente
vediamo come sta subito perché le parli
di aspirapolveri ma sei scemo ma non sai
che cos'è la galanteria tu eccola eccola
tutta carica grande zia bella l'iberica
anche lei c'ha voglia di conoscermi dove
entra entra entro far entrare ovvero ma
cosa fa ma si sa che i problemi ajo
entrata leiva che galanteria che c'hai
come uomo possiamo andare in viaggio
katrina ti incontrerà all'iva e andiamo
al museo conferma ralle ma sempre triste
6 maxi triste non sono una compagnia
così schifosa io la velista barca
ecco questa questa barca un giorno non
sarà neanche tua perché con i soldi che
ho speso per quella catapecchia che
chiamo casa non mi è rimasto man con
simone on die proviamoci maledizione
chiedi se single
la vedo che è una scalpitante vai
chiedilo chiedilo da andate o quella
pensa già ai bambini ma è scema quindi
saprei se avessimo mai un bambino
scappare sti in messico si è preso tutto
da mio zio preso tutto primo bacio
speed run la speed run più vera della
storia dei videogiochi il primo bacio
dato in tre minuti larga come ho fatto
non lo so neanch'io dove alleva la zia e
fa così schifo che sapevo di bagna cauda
è andata via eccolo quando bellissima
portami la mia regia entra dentro vador
mi fa col quale quali sono i miei mille
bisogni che non ho soddisfatto conclude
vescica fame energia aiuto sto morendo
media di andare in giro vai a mangiare
ma il cielo da cucinare si torta al
cioccolato ma che pande morto in maniera
un bel pandemie earth ora il toy un
pasto veloce latte acqua biscotti a
forma di animali ma che problemi hai
ebbe una volta ho mangiato a casa di mio
zio antonio è stato orribile
complimenti a chi ha visto nessuno trova
solo 4 milioni di persone iscritte al
mio canale hai fatto una figura un po di
kakà ma non ti ha visto nessuno tra in
quel doccia una goccia riflessiva una
doccia calda e sensuale e quanti modi
per far la doccia ci sono il suo gioco
di reclame al letto vuol dire che vado
avanti ha letto gli urlo e mio questo
letto
basta a posto la notte in teoria passa
sempre veloce comunque sono riuscito a
fare il primo bacio incredibile ma una
domanda quest'uomo qua ci va a lavoro
con non fa niente dal mattino a sera
come gli youtubers no perché non mi
tengo in casa uno che che accoltella le
padelle credimi non lo voglio fare a
caterina calia niente io come lavoro
faccio il playboy o rimorchio la gente
ho finalmente posso comprare qualcosa
mio dio vado avanti riusciamo a fare 600
si muove con questa roba
ma siete scelgo un più ter compatto
quanto puoi scendere il tablet cosa sto
leggendo riportato il pandemonio compito
segretissimo va beh io prenderei un
tablet o prendiamolo nerone tyrol i
jukebox gioioso subito lo voglio
immediatamente dove come ho fatto non
acquistarlo prima d'ora mento qua
sospendendo tutti i soldi che mi
rimaneva non me ne frega niente lo
voglio jukebox dobbiamo provare ascolta
musica ci sarà martin garics spero anche
se un jukebox
sì ciao aspetta che sto pisciando un
secondo priorità la vescica
ciao tutto bene voi pisciare anche tu
ciao ciao fieri di diventare la
fidanzata perché no mammamia regala
quattro sono contento oggi diventata la
fidanzata di dinho ma sono un fenomeno
oggi un fenomeno raga un fenomeno allora
non so non succede ma se succede
macché
ci ho messo di meno che quelli del
grande fratello ragazzo che da far
schifo ma ok va bene come come possibile
questa cosa come raga sono allibito sono
cena posto per tutta la vita basta
ap ok non so cosa non è possibile non ci
posso credere che di esserci riuscito
subito non è che mi rimane incinta ma
che vado in messico invita a restare per
la notte vai che omo ragazze o passare
una notte insieme mi sembra un'ottima
idea
ora devo proprio andare grazie per la
compagnia ci vediamo dopo appena detto
sì a te ne vai sei stupido di voi questi
biscotti si grazie a una fame da lupi
eco tieni allora no no grazie non ho
fame cosa schiena dolorante per il letto
economico ai al materasso era duro come
il cemento e non solo il materasso e hp
se senti ho comprato dormi sul jukebox
non è più soldi per comprare matera suit
arrangi con quello che già era gay dire
che possiamo concludere che questa
partita per provare la versione console
è stata una notte è un'ottima palestra o
non sono riuscito in tutte le versioni
che ho provato v the sims a fare figli
ft al primo video ps4 subito subito
proprio il gancio uscita all'espansione
cani e gatti su pc sicuramente più anti
proverò anche quella e farò anche la
versione sul telefono così lo fate tutte
che the sims mobile per avere sia
preceduto ragazzi cosa in se vi è
piaciuto l'argomento è un mi piace
questo video lo merita sicuramente al
momento le fiki fiki dovevate
schiacciarlo ma da essere un istinto e a
firenze mi è piaciuto a molti piace che
la risposta da scrivere e noi ci vediamo
un prossimo visto dai ragazzi
c'è poi il sito mi è passata fuori di
casa